Someday, we'll have our last conversation And drink our last cup of coffee.
Someday, we might be eighty And think about the different things we used to say.
All the memories of you will just become a ghost of a smile Caught in the wind.
Someday, it'll be the last day.
Someday, it could be over The moon could seem so far away Despite... All the adventures that we promised We'd go on... Again...
Then and again... All the memories of you and all the stories We were a part of... Lost in the wind... Someday... Someday... It'll be the last day...
I won't forget how it feels to be loved To be remembered by someone as special as you Someday... I will... Drink the last cup of coffee... With a smile...
... path thatstreamed...
I won't forget how it feels to be loved.
To be remembered by someone as special as you.
Someday, I will drink the last cup of coffee with a smile.